what's up sweetie where you going  yeah  hey  i know you're on tv  you're just looking for like  non-edible things that you can eat  sure  look it look it  don't eat that please don't need that oh  why do you do that why do you do that  why do you do that  that can't feel good  look at her  look at that  i buy you all these chew sticks and yet  and yet  you just keep doing that  i know i i don't know what your deal is  i don't know what your deal is  i know  you can't help it it's an addiction oh  now you're gonna chew that one all right  damn  she's getting all all into that  getting all into it  why  why pookie  it's part of her eternal quest to get  pookie droll all over everything  yeah no  oh look what you did  you're messing up daddy's valentine's  day card  she she just ate that right off of there  not a sentimentalist i take it  obviously  oh goodness  yeah you sick of that okay